Marla Fernández y su hija de seis meses
sobrevivieron a la selva del Darién
cuenta que en su trayecto para llegar a
Estados Unidos debió ser auxiliada por
otros migrantes porque no tenía fuerzas
para cargar a su bebé
lo peor que vive en la selva el
desespero de ver sufrir a mi niña porque
si sufren los niños sufren y bastante
los que dicen que los niños no sufren es
mentira los niños sufren mucho mucho
mucho en esa selva y pues no no le deseo
ninguna madre que meta a sus hijos por
esa por esa selva
Marcos vitora mientras hacían su propia
travesía ayudó a mujeres y niños a salir
de la selva caminando nos encontramos un
niño que la mamá me los dio a mí para
llevar adelante con el guía y yo tuve
que cargarlo porque dijera mamá la dejé
muy lejos y tuve que esperarla a ella
mira aquí Yo tengo dos niños cargado
lloviendo voy a traer otra niña pero
como ya tenemos un poco de peso pesado
pero no solo los niños son vulnerables
en este peligroso viaje las mujeres
también están propensas a sufrir ataques
sexuales
grizbelis Oropeza además de ser estafada
por los coyotes estuvo cerca de ser
abusada Pues sí me sentí un poco
incómoda porque un indio me ofreció
plata y no me querían dejar salir de la
playita porque
quería que yo me acostara con él y él me
iba a dar 200 dólares de verdad que sí
violan a mujeres y las violan es un
poquito complicado para nosotros las
mujeres yo tuve suerte gracias a Dios
pero su caso no es aislado Pese a que
las autoridades panameñas son
conscientes de los delitos argumentan
que lo impenetrable de la selva no les
permite actuar a tiempo contra los
criminales la denuncia que presentan
ellos son de robos por parte de
originarios pues del sector que se
aprovechan de la vulnerabilidad de estos
migrantes que vienen en ese afán de
llegar al a Norteamérica y Canadá
el adicional Pues hay algunas femeninas
que presentan denuncias ante el
Ministerio Público de violación
las víctimas de la travesía son
incalculables no hay manera de tener un
registro de niños muertos o de mujeres
violadas el miedo a las amenazas de las
bandas violentas y decir que los hijos
quedaron muertos en la selva impide
obtener datos fidedignos es algo que los
migrantes prefieren borrar de su memoria
y continuar su camino